[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
quack
[Music]
s
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
week 14
NFL bets we love
my name is Greg Garvey next to me is the
man the myth the legend Sam Richmond and
next to him is the man that's undefeated
your undefeated producer Ryan I mean you
came on here before the show you came on
here talking talking your talk you know
just want to let you guys know I'm
undefeated all right so now the the
floor is yours right the floor is yours
go ahead take it away You're undefeated
bro yeah well I didn't come with this
stat there was you know we have some
right heads who are who are in the chat
uh always who let me know hey by the way
you know you've made me so much money
I'm so rich now because of you are you
allergic to losing so I went to the
doctor and I I figured it out I am
allergic to losing I I can't lose it's
not healthy for me uh I don't know if
you guys saw last week that Browns game
they fumble six pick six punt return
touchdown those are the three touchdowns
that they scored we had the team total
under 27 and a half uh one by the hook
uh so if I lost if I lost on those three
touchdowns uh I don't know if I would
have showed up today but again we can't
we cannot lose right now it's impossible
that's crazy I mean how you I'm over
here I'm speechless I don't even know
what to say bro like you won by the hook
you you took the Browns under 27 and a
half under 27 and a half yes and and
they scored 27 points three
non-offensive touchdowns and you won by
the hook man you can't be no hotter than
that welcome to the show though
everybody welcome to the show I'm gonna
introduce everybody again because the
new people that just logged on to the
show you guys got to know who I'm here
with I'm here with the man the myth of
Legend Sam Richmond is next to me and
next to him is the man that's 4-0 Ryan
producer Ryan as we call him we are
giving away our Best Bets for today drop
your locks in the chat we'll be grading
your picks at the end of the show but
right now we need your help to build
another anytime touchdown parlay Ryan
get in there and tell the people what we
need from them we need your anytime
touchdown locks I'm sorry I just saw a
onion strap we need a plus 4 000 leg
Ryan uh so we're already we're already
on track uh but we need we need your
lock so we need what you like uh who you
like to score an anytime touchdown today
we're gonna build three legs uh and then
we're gonna bet it and ride as a family
and hopefully cash is a squad so it's
been a few weeks so I know you guys are
gonna be like oh well we have it we
haven't hit in a few weeks we need it to
be safe no we need to get rich we we
need to get rich so uh drop what you
like I already see Sports Z Pro says
Tony Pollard
guys
you said that earlier bro I did say it
earlier Ryan is like paying commenters
to plant his picks
that might be
God sorry it might be what's going on
nah go ahead Ryan that might be what's
going on though I'm just I'm just
concurring with Sam I'm just like that
might be you might be paying these
commenters to ride with your picks Ryan
I'm reaching out in the Bleacher Report
DM saying hey I need you to drop I need
you to drop Tony Pollard Titans to come
Titans to come to be honest Tony parlor
what is that minus 120 that's a leg
I mean let's ask the audience let's
let's ask the people though let's let's
ask them if you guys want Tony Pollard
thumbs up you guys don't want Tony pilot
thumbs down in the comments I like that
though Ryan talk talk to us though talk
to the people why do you think
like you got to win a sober bro like
because you know they're playing the
Texans we know that but you think Tony
Pollard's getting in today uh I see
enrad who says Pollard's been flat uh I
prefer Zeke I disagree on the Parlor
it's been flat I think the thing with
Pollard is like the Cowboys are going to
score a ridiculous amount of points
today they may be the first NFL team to
ever score 100 points today against the
Houston Texans so it's it may happen but
uh
he can do things in the passing game
that Zeke cannot and I think having that
flexibility with your running back who
is also going to get a lot of carries uh
is huge and that's what you're looking
for in anytime TD plays like if you're
going with Zeke you kind of need the
Cowboys to fall around the goal line I'm
not necessarily sure that'll happen
today
so yeah opposite of that I want the goal
line back over the guy you need the
20-yard splash play like it's just he
gets like 12 15 carries and you need one
of those to break it's just it's tough
it's tough I don't know I will also say
though as a callback to how I feel about
the New York Giants uh the Houston
Texans run defense is stinky poo like
they they are poop that's why I'm saying
Zeke I'm I'm going Zeke there but I
don't know we could I I'm going for the
one with more value better value sorry
good I hear you guys the chat I I just
want to just jump in here and say like
the chat oh I did see a lot of thumbs up
on Tony Paul I mean so like you guys are
feeling it just keep on putting those
thumbs up Ryan take a look at the chat I
see a lot of thumbs up for for my man
Tony Pollard Sam I love your I love Zeke
too but
the people you know
I mean we we need the full get in here
all right the thumbs ups and thumbs
Downs are starting to come in so yeah
we've got to give them some time but
yeah M Phillips says Pollard is a lock
uh we have a good stat here from bagel
and lox who says so here's a fun uh stat
thing only two Texan players have
shorter odds than the Cowboys defense
like I said guys yeah that's pretty
insane yeah some Zeke is starting to pop
in the trash look you know I do see Zeke
Sam I do see Zeke I'm not gonna lie all
right I do we yeah there's okay there's
a lot of Z glove I all right if we're
gonna listen if we're gonna do this
we'll we will we will start off with
we'll start off with Zeke I'll you guys
cool wow that's That's Good Vibes by
Ryan Ryan usually doesn't concede this
early so that makes me feel good that's
because like two and three are gonna be
crazy
just setting me up here you're setting
me up we all right let's do it we're
added Zeke all right
okay so we need cheese Jay Williams
Derek Henry anytime I was I was just
about to read that I was just about to
read that last week we wrote with
Derrick Henry I mean this week James
that was all the chat the chat was just
pushing Derek Henry and I was like all
right fine we can do Derek Henry but
yeah the direct quote that people are
passing around are can I offer a boring
one and then he said Derek Henry that's
not true it was all the chat yes of
course
uh okay let's I saw somebody
trouble trouble since 1983 says why not
both now I'm not advocating for this I
we just have to answer questions like he
said why not vote
it's not a bad take it's not it's not
it's not a bad take it's just my my take
is like if the Cowboys start pouring it
on
the starters are gonna sit
so like you don't want to have to rely
on
you know I just don't think you want to
have to rely on two Cowboys here I think
one is fine
a lot of Jamal Williams loving the
channel
sorry yeah
you're good a lot of Jamal Williams is
in the chat Maddie 2x says Williams uh
Jeffrey Adams Jamal TD Jamal TD Williams
we have to go look at it right I know I
I see that and there's Jacoby there's a
lot of love for this game Jacoby won
says amen Ross St Brown lock T.J
Hawkinson lock
hey hey you saw how you squeezed in TJ
Hawkinson in there
I'm reading the comment guys TJ
Hawkinson returns to Detroit the the
team that traded him in the middle of
the season and he's plus 190 to score a
touchdown
I mean how many targets did he get last
week probably I'm a big targets guy
probably so many probably so many I
actually I actually do not hate
Hawkinson because this is like to your
point Ryan like they will probably want
to get him a touchdown against his
former team and if they are in the Red
Zone I could I could see that happening
so there's gonna be a ton of points too
I just don't think the Vikings can do
that though like what do you think they
could just be like oh we want to get
caucus in a touchdown so we're just
going to feed him against that Lion's
defend you think that they're just gonna
call like what they wanted for Greg to
transition into Justin Jefferson which
I'm which I'm all for
yeah he he's not plus money right here
that's true yeah he got six targets last
week he had four for 33 against the Jets
so you know not what you love to see do
you like it is plus 190 against his
former team I this just feels where's
Jamal Williams Jamal Williams is right
there minus 120.
what's up people want Jamal Williams I
do yeah let's do this in the chat thumbs
up or thumbs down for Jamal Williams I
like when the chat gets flooded with
thumbs up or thumbs down okay so here we
forgot I need to read some chat here
schmidty says I like TJ for two TDS or
more Revenge game Elrod Hawkinson space
46 Hawkinson probably first TD
uh
uh hey Ryan I want this that's Riley
says I want the stats on Revenge games
and reading them off because literally
I'm seeing Williams lock well oh I see
Williams JJ SJ says Williams lock and
then uh what's Travis Kelsey Adam Phelan
Gary Wilson Adam thielen Joe Dean said
Adam thielen but we're not talking about
Adam thielen
it was I I thought we were between Jamal
Williams and
they want Jay will yeah they watch a lot
okay how about this you guys tell us
Jamal Williams or TJ Hawkinson and
that'll be the play that we make okay
you guys say their name write their name
down no thumbs up a thumbs down
that's all you need to write okay well
or Hawk okay we can move on to another
leg while the jaywill hawk situation
gets well they're coming in already Sam
they're coming in I see Williams I see
Williams as a lock
wait hold on let me read the the
uh gortz e says Hawk lock well that's
seven comments are Williams
exactly
a lot of Williams in there right
a lot of what Jamal Williams in there
right sorry
this is Juicy this is Juicy Juicy
it's plus money baby
that's all we look for this is a little
this seems lucky to me bro I'm not gonna
lie oh my God all right what what's next
this is we can throw another juicy one
at you minus 215.
is this
that sounds lucky
uh and you know the Chad is gonna be
like echler lock echler lock take
Eclipse hey Ryan hold on hold on hold on
you got a real good really good take for
you right I'm sorry go ahead uh bagel
and locks is in the comments and said
Donovan Knight bro yeah he's probably
like minus 250. no
no he's not all right he's plus 215
sorry yeah there you go I apologize
that's up your that's up your ass right
that is yeah but it's against the bills
it's gonna be so you know it is fine
Ryan only wants the juicy one if he
originates it
he wants the credit he wants the glory
of Iceland that's not true that is not
true I'm just trying to think it's sub
30 degrees in Buffalo
like I don't know 15 carries last week
14 the week before hey actually hold on
plus 862 is not bad
is now what does the chat think of
Donovan okay I also just like the amount
of hashtag hot locks that I'm seeing not
to you know not to go back but you paid
those people so let's move on
we gotta shout out twin number two said
this is my weekly Sunday morning comedy
show in all caps we appreciate the love
we're sending you some VR bedding socks
we love that Sam you love sending
people's socks
guys we've got a bowl of socks you gotta
get rid of so we have too many songs
I need some of those socks those
thoughts are fresh and those socks are
fresh um guys guys all right so are are
we asking the audience are we locking in
Donovan Knight now yeah someone threw
out an interesting one Stephen Diggs not
Stefon Diggs and I you know I don't know
the odds are in Stevie Diggs but kind of
in on that I'm not gonna lie
minus 125 what does that take it too
right I I tried to click out of that
fast you didn't see it uh plus 450. no
thank you thank you Sam I don't like
that now the onion says Kate Otten or
Boston Scott
how do we feel about K dot in love
when this hits guys
this is probably right here
why did we move hops out of it
I feel like we're right there and then
it's just like left Boston Scott because
look at that look at look at the look at
the comments right now Sam they're all
saying hell no
I think to Donovan
uh all right we need we need another
take we need another take to discuss
somebody said Boston Scott is crazy
versus the Giants wow hey hey Ryan let's
just look at this one I saw uh Hopkins I
saw hop Hopkins in the comments somebody
commented uh Hopkins I just want to see
what it what is what's his numbers uh
we're gonna have to wait till Monday
night to
cash that one
yeah yeah
um it might not be a yeah it might not
be worth it but let's just we'll we're
men of the people
yeah we are men of people we have to do
our due diligence you know it's an
interesting one or an interesting
potential we go Sunday night game we try
and create a last leg Stitch Keenan
Allen or or Mikey Williams against
poverty Dolphins defense
I told you guys about Keenan Allen last
week I told you guys about Keenan guys
can we pick receivers that are going to
finish the game
he finished the game last week
also Mike Williams not even on the
injury report
oh my God forever pharah saying Mark
Andrews we talked about this before the
show Mark Andrews goes off with Tyler
Huntley as his quarterback now I'm not
gonna lie we did talk about that but and
those numbers those numbers were
beautiful were they not it's risky
though
my man Caden Allen went for six for 88
in the touchdown last year I mean last
week average 14 yards per catch baller
well there's a lot of Tyler Lockett love
I don't know if anyone on our side
mentioned Tyler Lockett but out of
nowhere just like Tyler lockett's been
scoring
Maddie 2x lock it
let's see what it's looking like Alvin
lock it all right all right yeah we are
out of this gross Monday Night Football
game uh Tyler Lockett where the Seahawks
at right here the Tyler lock you play is
not of us play 45. I played him in
fantasy the other day
I mean the chat likes Tyler Lockett
all right here we go here we go let's
ask the chat chat you guys are rocking
with Tyler Lockett we need a lot of
Thumbs Up need a lot of Thumbs Up in the
chat if you guys are rocking with Tyler
Lockett if you're not thumbs down
he's plus 145 they're taking on the
Carolina Panthers in Seattle fellas
this game is happening in Seattle
Ryan look at your face
um
I'm not going to get over TJ Hawkinson I
won't lie
that's where you make the Ryan special
parlay and it's Tony Pollard it's
Hawkinson and it's whatever [ __ ]
other tight end you want to throw it
yeah it's Mark Andrews yes okay
so that's the Ryan special and this is
our parlay okay
uh
I yeah I mean listen I'm I love Tyler
Lockett Tyler Lockett scores a lot uh
this is yeah
do we wanna all right we'll go thumbs up
or thumbs down
go look go look there yeah Brandon
Michael that's five thumbs up that's a
that's a five star review right there
Vapor man
almost 10 thumbs up uh Quan four thumbs
up DeJuan Jackson three thumbs up uh s
does losno four thumbs down uh probably
because they want the Ryan special trust
me I'm with you guys but we got it we
gotta stick to the plan Maddie 2x hail
the Ryan's special yeah you can give out
the Ryan's special at the end yeah so
I'll give out the Ryan special I'll
tweet it we'll be good we'll be good
guys we'll we'll win both how about that
we will win both
um
twit number two says Ryan is chock full
of Hawk that is true uh kick flip kid a
ton of thumbs all right there's love
there's love for this parlay let's lock
this in yeah let's lock it in let's lock
it in we're gonna lock this one in Ryan
um One More Time One More Time read the
parlay Falls read it for the new people
that just joined the show this is what
we are riding with I feel good about
this I do so it's Zeke minus 150 for the
first leg Jamal Williams not TJ
Hawkinson minus 120 for the second leg
Tyler Lockett is our third leg at plus
145. you cook that all together it's a
three leg parlay that adds up to plus
648 it is a lock it is hitting we will
be back this week we're back I think
we're back guys we're back we're back
we're back on The Winning Side this week
we're going to speak it into existence
make sure you guys tell us on DraftKings
and it wouldn't be Sunday guys if I
didn't do a little anytime TD boost
magic so we're also going to boost
Dalvin cook anytime touchdown from minus
145
to plus 100. there it is we're gonna
boost it for you guys see it right there
on the screen but now
it's time for my man Sam six Best Bets
Sam you brought us six bets we're
sending Ryan back to the chat we're
gonna send Ryan back to the chat let's
start off with your first pick can we
please get 45 seconds on the clock
Sam we're gonna get right to it we're
gonna waste no time and we're counting
how many times you say dvoa I just want
you to know so let's go let's get right
to it all right let's do it we're
starting off hot we're starting off
controversial I think you're on the
other side of this game too so it should
be interesting but my favorite pick of
the day is Lions money line at minus
130.
um I know people are really surprised
when this line came out that the lions
were favored but to me the lions are
just they're sorry the Vikings are just
the luckiest team like we've ever seen
just historically lucky
um I know Ryan has a tweet that uh I
paid him to bring up after after I'm
done but this is a below average team in
my opinion they're they're 20th in dvoa
which is a spot below the Atlanta
Falcons they're consistently getting out
gained they're consistently winning
games they shouldn't win and meanwhile
the lions are playing really good
football they're at home they're in a
dome their defense has really improved I
really really like the Lions today I
think they finally end this Vikings luck
Sam likes the Lions I do not but that is
okay because it's not about what I like
it's not about what uh say I'm like it's
about what you guys like you guys the
people and let's get let's talk to the
people there he is producer Ryan
producer Ryan what is the chat talking
about well first uh Sam I'll give you my
venmo after the show of course and yeah
cool uh but we pulled up this tweet from
Aaron Schatz to uh
you know back up your propaganda Vikings
will go from the first team ever with
negative dvoa at nine and two to the
first team ever with negative dvoa at 10
and two two thousands Vikings will be
the only other 10-2 team within 15
percentage points of them
so they're historically lucky we've
never seen a team this bad if you don't
know what dboa is just the point is
we've never seen a team this bad be
attended to and it's just completely
unsustainable and the lions are good so
that's it I'm done yeah uh but the chat
jackham Lions is a lock and dropped not
one two lock emojis
Justin right breath what's up wait wait
wait wait wait hold on do you got people
making fake Pages bro I see a producer
Ryan in the comments no that's me oh
that's oh okay okay I'm sorry I'm sorry
I thought Ryan had people making fake
babies that's amazing
I I did not mean that to interrupt your
mojo keep going bro keep going no no all
good uh kr5 says this guy goes against
the Vikings every week damn right you do
I do I do I do and they've beat me like
hand up but I just I don't think it's
sustainable uh and I did get them one
week when the Cowboys beat them by 75
points so uh yes yes good times good
times uh mhp4 I like Detroit uh Justin
colbreath Jamal Williams first time uh
first touchdown uh we already touched on
this man Jeffrey Adams lions with a
thumbs up emoji uh lines are getting a
lot of love the lions are maybe they're
America's team they might be America's
team and they might find their Campbells
hey let's send producer Ryan back to the
chat Sam you got one pick you gave us
one pick you got five more to go so we
get 45 seconds on the clock there it is
Sam take it away
all right so my next pick well the line
is actually moved here a good amount so
I have Browns plus five and a half I
think it's at four well right now which
will have producer Ryan confirm maybe
lower
um I still like it at four but
um to me that's just a really really bad
situational spot for the Bengals
um I like this Bengals team a lot but
again this is just a really tough spot
for them they're coming off a monster
win against the Chiefs they've heard all
week what Nick Saban would call rat
poison about how good they are they're
going back to the Super Bowl this stuff
and having to play a divisional opponent
with this many points is just too much
and and the Browns are playing well you
know they've they've won two in a row
you got another week to you know get
acclimated with the quarterback switch
um so I like them here and and you get a
little value just based on the line
inflation because I think it originally
well I guess now it's back down to four
but at five and a half the line was a
little bit inflated after the Bengals
big win
Sam are you are do you have any optimism
are you skeptical at all after seeing
that offense from Cleveland last week it
wasn't good I know Ryan touched on it
that all of their points are off you
know special teams and defense but I
think you get another week again
acclimated the quarterback change and I
also like them to just slow this game
down with Chubb it's what they do which
really bodes well for an underdog so
um I I do still like the Browns even
though yeah they did look not great
offense I do want to say this I do want
to say this my man Ryan gave us a scoop
before the show he says the Bengals do
not play the Browns will so go look at
the trends Go Peep it might be onto
something he might be onto something two
down four more to go 45 seconds on the
clock please
there it is Sam take it away all right
this next one is very scary just for me
personally because the next time I win a
bet on a game involving the Tennessee
Titans will be the first one because
this team just kills me when I bet on
them they get smoke but I bet against
them they lose but I really like the
Jags this week at plus three and a half
look the times are just a mess right now
um they can't run the ball this two
weeks in a row where they've just been
totally stopped on the ground they're
now down to I think 20th and rough Rush
offense dvoa which really matters a lot
when your quarterback is Ryan Tannehill
who's kind of hobbled and you have no
offensive weapons like they they just
really don't have anything going for
them so for me this is more of a total
fade of the Titans than it is a play on
the Jags but I do like buying a little
low on the Jags and after they got
smoked last week and a Muslim spot to
save their season but times on they're
on my [ __ ] list again I'm totally out on
them
the Titans are on Sam's [ __ ] list so
he's rocking with Jacksonville plus
three and a half Sam that's three picks
that you got I I'm just in the comments
and and I see Ryan talking to himself in
the comments well I don't I really don't
know what's going on with that guy he's
literally talking about identity theft
in the comments we'll bring him into
here in a minute but uh Sam we got three
picks three more to go uh 45 seconds on
the clock please thank you there it is
go ahead Sam
all right my next pick is Panthers plus
four
um another gross one that I'm sure the
chat will hate
um look I bet on the Seahawks team a lot
to start the year but to me I'm starting
to get concerned with them they've had a
few weeks in a row where their defense
has just looked really suspect they gave
up a million yards the Raiders on the
ground they let John Wofford almost
Wilford however you pronounce it uh
almost beat them last week they needed
to really scrape by to win that game uh
they just haven't been playing as well
and Carolina like give them credit they
have their defense has been amazing the
last few weeks so they've given up 28
points total in the last three weeks
they've been fighting with an interim
coach Sam darnold has looked competent
fighting for his NFL life so they're not
tanking the season away and I just don't
think the Seahawks are playing well
enough to Warrant being this big a favor
it's even at home so so Sam you're
baking on a close game here banging on a
close game field goal game okay field
goal game okay I like that I like that
like because Seattle at home that's a
tough that's a tough tough win
they did lose to the poverty Raiders
though two weeks ago they did and I said
the same thing I said you know what I
like to say I'm like that's four four
and four down two more to go Sam can we
get 45 seconds on the clock please there
it is let's go Sam all right if I
already haven't lost the chat which I
feel like the last few weeks that I got
the chat on my side and I think this
week I'm just gonna totally lost them
which is which is okay but this one is
gonna lose them I am taking the Denver
Broncos plus nine and a half look this
is this is gross it gets I totally get
it like don't watch this game but I
think at the end of the game you will
look up and you'll see your bet as
cashier
um the Broncos defense is still playing
really really well
um and this is just too many points at
home in a divisional game you give me a
defense that is generally speaking
allowing 14 points a week like I'm
taking 10 points and they're obviously
not gonna hold the Chiefs to 14 points
but either the Chiefs get 20 24 all you
really need is two touchdowns from the
Broncos which I know is scary with
Russell Wilson but the Chiefs defense is
25th in defensive DBA they have a really
bad defense and I just I put my faith in
Rust that he can get me two touchdowns
and cover this number but it's just too
many points
Sam's putting his face in faith in Rust
so you might need to get on your knees
and pray brother because putting your
face arrest this year I don't know it's
been done mostly the Broncos defense I
just want two touchdowns for us just
give me two
Sam wants two touchdowns I want to know
what's going on in the chat let's bring
producer Ryan back in here because my
man is in the chat talking to himself I
think it's what it looks like or I don't
know if he has people my identities
there's somebody in the chat who has no
followers not following anybody no
profile picture producer underscore Ryan
that is not me
my I didn't even have time to see how
they feel about you've got a check mark
I do have a check mark I'm verified oh
yeah producer Ryan's verified
on that my goodness uh all right let's
get to the actual takes well I'm on I
was on the phone with the FBI during
that so identity theft is not is not a
joke uh the onions Russ says more Russ
has more toilets than past passing
touchdowns uh that might be true I don't
know how big his house is uh he also
said he likes the over and the Vikings
and Lions game uh specco says I love
four out of five but Denver just can't I
get that I totally get that like I roast
a Broncos pick I get it but I do think
it's gonna hit yeah
um
let's see M Taylor said you're picking
some suspect teams today uh
there was somebody who didn't like your
backing of the Panthers because of Sam
darnold I'm trying to find who that was
but uh I would imagine that most of the
chat does not enjoy you backing sent
Arnold I mean yeah I'm loving the chat
not positive this week that's okay you
know I you know I I take that I take
that in I try to do my best to put
forward some winners and you know we'll
see we'll see at the next week if the
chat won our final one hey hey this is
hilarious bro the chat really the chat
trigger way has a dvoa counter on Sam he
says Sam I love it away four keep them
coming no he said keep counting so
apparently you said dvoa four that's not
that many times I'm proud of myself I
mean 109 and a half I'm thrilled with
that
uh jump to five it just went up to five
but uh the live line right now is
currently at ten and a half and we are
taking bets you guys can uh DM me
no but that's super funny that we got
the audience actually counting Sam's
dvoa uh how many times he said I I love
it I love it get back in there Ryan get
back what else are they talking yeah no
we got some late love from doctor87 and
Devin flowers both Dr 87 says Panthers
win uh Devin flowers says Carolina plus
four and Denver plus nine and a half
love them both uh Joe Dean says he loves
the Denver pick I put them in my parlay
so we had some late love come in for the
back end of your picks there
um that maybe were gross stinky
oh
my bad producer Ryan but Sam you're
getting some love in the comments they
they want to know your Twitter your
Twitter handle so give them your Twitter
handle VR so just my name and then where
I work pretty simple no understanding
not underscore guy
make sure y'all tap in with Sam Sam also
we got dad oh nominator 88 he's new to
the show he said that he was new to the
show and he hoped that he can come here
and get some unbiased plays from us so
welcome to the show thank you for tuning
in but Sam uh he's new to betting so Dad
ominator 88 says what's dboa so explain
it to him dvoa so there's obviously just
a bunch of advanced metrics out there
and I think dvoa does the best job of
sort of combining everything about
football into just very basic numbers to
understand in rankings but it basically
just accounts for every single play
that's happening is being graded and
looked at at factors in strength of
schedule it factors in luck it factors
and all that [ __ ] that the Vikings suck
at and are somehow winning games when
you get out gained by 200 yards and
still win a game your dvoa can drop even
though your record might increase so
it's just a really good Advanced metric
that I think encapsulate everything that
happens in a game Ryan there's breaking
news in the chat Sam thank you that was
a great that was a great great it's
breaking news in the chat there's like
five there's like five producer Ryan
where they're like they're like
colonizing right now I did want to touch
on a comment uh Noel guadarama says Ryan
is a loser spelled with two s's why
y'all still got this man given picks
guys I'm 4-0 the real producer Ryan look
it bro oh my God that's super funny all
right let's send Ryan back to the chat
because I I strongly feel he's making
all of these these these things
unfair you know what is unfair is you
guys bet the over on live dvoa and then
read a comment where I had to say it
four times and now drink away has got me
at like eight and I probably said it two
more times for the overest cash so dvoa
dvoa you guys win
all right hey let's send Ryan back to
the chest Ryan you're going to come back
here soon 45 seconds on the clock Sam we
got five picks we need one more let's
get to it brother
all right last pick Chargers plus three
and a half
um I bet against the Chargers a lot this
year but I think this is a really good
buy low spot with an inflated line
um we've talked a lot about this show
how important I think it is when the
Chargers have their full complement of
offensive weapons Kane Island healthy
Mike Williams healthy not even on the
injury report
um and like I you know the Dolphins
defense is bad like it's just not good
it's been average below average all year
they got lit up by Brock Purdy last week
and like Niners are obviously really
good but to me that's a pretty bad look
uh to get beat up by Brock Purdy coming
off the bench and uh and I think the
biggest hold the Chargers have is their
Rush defense well the Dolphins don't
really run the ball that much they're
game is through the air and the Chargers
are competent through past defense so
just too many points to the charges at
home Buy Low on that team and a savior
season type spot in my opinion there it
is my man Sam's rocking with the
Chargers plus three and a half I see s
Riley 99. he's been bro he's been riding
with your picks the whole day but he
says he likes to charge his money line
shout out to you s Riley let's bring
producer Ryan back in here because he's
going to talk about the chat he's
probably going to talk about all the
fake accounts that he's uh that he's
paying people to make guys there's so
many producer Ryan
and like all the other producer Ryan's
are like calling out the other producer
Ryan's to stop being fake and I I've
lost control I've lost control of the
chat I'm a man of the chat but I've lost
full control
hey there producer Ryan says producer
Ryan to unite I'm trying United in the
chat man I tried to form a super team
with the other producer Ryan so we just
stopped fighting each other but it's
it's not going to happen they all want
to be their own producer Ryan I get it
um all right specco says yes without a
healthy uh Armstead tour will struggle
um
producer Ryan Rye guys unite uh
there's so much producer Ryan talking
here right now with these fake accounts
uh a schrenecker says Derwin James out
does that concern you Sam
it does I mean I expected that so no not
not super concerned
um and I think the arms I think
armstead's gonna play but I do think
he's banged up and I just I I just have
not liked what I've seen from this
Dolphins defense
um
and uh and yeah I just I don't know if
they're gonna be able to protect you
with uh with a banged up Armstead okay
so with that with that note on the
Dolphins defense slime 83 jumped in here
and said charges Chargers Dolphins over
I know that's not the pick that you gave
out and I know it's not a direct cut I
don't hate that I don't hate that I just
don't bet totals like I I just there's
no really Rhyme or Reason behind it I
just spreads are more fun to me but I
don't hate it yeah and I will say the
total in that game is 55. uh that is an
absurd total that that's a like a
college football total
um sonoa says Derwin James out waddle
Hill going off take their props
uh yeah quenji says I like Chargers
money line so uh surprisingly I have the
people falling off on the Dolphins I'm
confused uh
yeah I don't know why they're falling
off on the Dolphins they played a good
49er team last week I'm just saying but
you know yeah no I don't know why no
bias there yeah no no bias I'm just
saying they shouldn't fall off on the
Dolphins they're a good team really good
team yeah
um Ryan are we done with the Chapman
should we move on or what's what's the
Vibes yeah yeah it's too much too much
fraud going on in the chat right now so
let's just move on too much fraud going
on in the chat too much uh producer
Ryan's they are uniting in the chat I
love to see it love to see it uh let's
move on you guys see it coming up coming
up you see it at the top of your screen
where it says Greg's pick yes we heard
from Sam
now I got a pick for you Ryan let's pull
up DraftKings oh actually you already
have it pulled up all right so look look
at guys Sam Ryan people in the chat
people that are watching we have a rule
here on this show we have a rule on the
show whenever you see Justin Jefferson
plus money to score a touchdown
you take it
today my man Justin Jefferson the score
touchdown he was minus I believe 140.
but I started scrolling I started
scrolling on DraftKings looking to find
my man Jeff Justin Jefferson uh with
some plus money and I found something
Ryan I found something I found Justin
Jefferson to score
in the Vikings to win can you please
click it so I can see what's the odds
Ryan Justin Jefferson is scoring the
Vikings to win that plus 200 it's plus
money Justin Jefferson is plus money I
think the Vikings are going to prove Sam
wrong all that dvoa metrics that he's
talking I think they're going to prove
him wrong and go into Detroit and go get
a win I think that they're going to do
that today and I think my man Justin
Jefferson is going to help them do that
against that Line's defense so I'm
locking this one in fellas I'm locking
this one in
I I think we need a side bet between uh
between me and you so uh maybe maybe the
chat can give suggestions for side bets
on on lions Vikings but uh but no yeah
yeah give us give us suggestions
definitely give us suggestions
uh
Ryan do you have a take on my play
you're kind of quiet bro no just no
disrespect I'm just I'm on the Lions
today so I can't I can't back that but
Fabian Cantu jumped in and said Browns
and Vikings money line today so you got
some love with the Vikings
oh yeah I know I got Ryan we have to
tell him why I picked the Vikings like I
literally asked you that question for a
reason you I asked you that question for
a reason so I want to let you guys know
when I came here before the show you
know we prep or whatever and I asked
Ryan told me that the Lions was a lot
today so immediately immediately after
that I roll with the Vikings and I'm
riding with the Vikings because it's an
auto fade of producer Ryan
Auto fade of the man who's 4-0 on this
show what what are we doing guys
can I just say just watching the fake
producer Ryan accounts giving like real
takes is so funny to me they're giving
picks they're giving analysis from fake
uh producer Ryan account so keep it up
we need to we need more fake producer
Ryan account I want to encourage
identity theft and fraud yeah okay Ryan
want to run it Sam Ryan's for a no but
real question he's four or no but what's
his dboa yeah it's it's a it's a fluke
yeah yeah right am I a lucky fraud
according to this it's worse it's worse
than the Vikings but all right I gave my
pick I gave my pick now it's time for
the Mr four or no Mr Producer Ryan Mr
fake count Mr verified himself Mr I need
plus 2 000 or better no I'm just kidding
let's go Ryan I tried to give you the
best intro but there it is like yeah I
appreciate that all right take it away
yeah step into my office okay we're four
now we're four now uh God on the show is
Owen one and I'm four now let's just let
that set get for a second uh mm M Mike
43 jumped in and said what's your take
on Giant Eagles Giants Eat You Dropped a
second take because we didn't answer him
he said Giants Eagles let's talk
the New York Giants may win this
football game today I will say that
straight up I know I've said on the show
that they're poop they're sticky poo
they stink they're a bad football team
all of that is true they may be one of
the worst teams in the NFL but don't let
the Giants know that they are heavy
underdogs to a division rival at home
they are plus seven and a half today on
DraftKings they're going to cover that
and they're going to cover it easily
we're not going to be I know I've said
oh we're 4-0 in the show next week I'm
going to come on and say we're 5-0 I
have not let you down one time guys the
New York Giants plus seven and a half it
is a lock it is hitting they may win the
game but we're taking the points that's
it that's all I have to say there it is
the Giants hit next week I really think
we should intro the show where Greg
calls Ryan the man the myth The Legend
and we start with Ryan's picks and I can
just comment on the back end
I won't advocate for it but if you want
that that's fair
no Ryan Ryan's Ryan's flooky he's like
the he's like the Viking he's like the
Vikings
he's like the Vikings he got to go like
he gotta go like seven eight no then
I'll start giving him credit but it's
unbelievable Ryan you'll be you'll be
happy to know that producer underscore
underscore underscore Ryan says I'm
riding with producer Ryan so there you
go
I I mean I I love that my own producer
Ryan fake accounts are backing me that
would be bad if they were it so I love
that
oh that hey uh all right so
we all locked in our picks Ryan talk to
us what are the people saying what are
what are they saying in the chat don't
read no I'm just kidding go ahead read
the producer Ryan read all the producer
runs we love those we love you guys
getting in the chat having some fun uh
sonoa says Eagles try and Def a trap
game stay away Trap game for the Eagles
for sure uh let's see we need we need
some bets we need some bets
um
because we want to grade them Mike White
Mike White anytime touchdown
oh I don't like that because they
weren't even they weren't even willing
to sneak him in the end zone to win the
game last week against the Vikings at
the one inch line so I'm still pissed
about that so no don't like it uh we had
a take from Dr 87 that said DeAndre
Swift anytime touchdown
out on it Lions win today
he also said sweat he said he said Swift
TD plus lines money line but I was
trying to get good vibes from Greg
so
uh Hey minus 110.
wait now what was that Ryan I'm sorry I
was reading the comments DeAndre Swift
anytime touchdown minus 110.
yeah I'm on the other side but like I
mean the pick is cool you know yeah all
right all right uh trigger weight uh two
uh over one and a half passing
touchdowns
over don't hate it gonna be a lot of
points in that game uh but a lot of
points okay
mhb for Kirk Cousins over two and a half
yards I'm assuming that's rushing I'm I
have to assume it's rushing well I will
say Kirk Cousins over two and a half
past yards that is my Play of the day so
I will take that that is an a
uh Anthony Pittman Mark answers anytime
touchdown plus 240. you got you already
know I was pushing I like it yes love it
we love it
now answer me that we love it but we
could put it I never said we couldn't
put in the parlay yeah did you ever find
your own demons man no no one said that
oh my God I did bring it up uh the stats
yes the stats from last year the people
choose that I know they brought it up uh
the two games that Mark Andrews played
with Tyler Huntley his stat line was 11
receptions 115 yards and a touchdown and
13 right here I have it highlighted 13
targets 10 receptions 136 yards and two
touchdowns I don't think there's gonna
be a lot of points in this game today
but if they're gonna score it's gonna be
Tyler Huntley to Mark Andrews uh this is
an A plus pick for me I agree all right
Lozano asked for the Ryan special so why
don't you give them the Ryan special
okay the Ryan's special I'm trying to
all right here we go TJ Hawkinson
anytime touchdown Mark Andrews anytime
touchdown
and Tony Pollard anytime touchdown
that's three legs I believe it's four I
believe it's plus fourteen hundred
fourteen to one it doesn't get better
than that that's how you get rich
there it is Ryan review all the picks
man let's review all the pics from today
before we say goodbye to the people okay
so our anytime touchdown parlay not the
Ryan special the other one that will hit
though uh Zeke Elliott minus 150 Jamal
Williams minus 120 Tyler Lockett plus
145 you parlay that I believe we said it
was around plus 686 uh and then our
anytime touchdown boost today is Dalvin
cook to even money plus 100.
there it is
there it is
and then our Sixpence we love which
would be Sam's picks Detroit Lions money
line Cleveland Browns plus five and a
half Jacksonville Jaguars plus three and
a half Carolina Panthers plus four
Denver Broncos plus nine and a half and
the Los Angeles Chargers plus three and
a half on Sunday night football against
the Miami Dolphins
there it is and then Greg's pick sir
Justin Jefferson anytime touchdown and
the Minnesota Vikings to win I was on
the page before Greg and you'll like
this it has now jumped to plus 215. so
we love that
yes uh and then my pick that will not
lose uh the New York Giants plus seven
and a half again if you like to if you
would like to get a little crazy you
might want to sprinkle on some money
line because they're gonna win but we
take it easy we'll take it safe and take
the points
so there it is that's all that's all our
picks that's all our picks for a lot of
picks today make sure you guys get on
DraftKings and tail with us guys
it's time to go win some money it's time
to go get rich it's time to go see a lot
of wins so let's sign off my name is
Greg Ivory next to me is the man the
myth the legend Sam Richmond and next to
him
is producer Ryan you real producer Ryan
the real producer Ryan the verified
producer Ryan we are out of here y'all
see y'all next week peace
[Music]
all right
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]